hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play resonance now
I this is another game that came out of
the asylum jam and it's got a really
really interesting feature to it which
if you can quite it's a little hard to
tell what's going on if you just first
look at it but in the bottom left hand
corner of the screen I'm actually
watching myself through a camera and I
hear something so yeah this was made in
48 hours and it was very ambition it's
slightly unfinished but oh it's got a
lot of potential from what I first saw
now I haven't played more than just
loading up the game so I don't know what
to expect but I hear something it's
sci-fi setting I love sci-fi horror
games okay so like when I walk into a
new room see that camera up in the
corner I'm shining my light at it right
now you can see that I'm watching myself
as I go in these rooms as I'm walking in
this room so you can see like my faint
outline on the shadow of that door and
my light beam as it goes up to the
camera and I'm assuming I haven't seen
anything yet but was it I'm assuming
that the only way I'll be able to see
monsters is by watching the cameras oh
is that something is that something
there that actually something there oh
oh I can't tell is that something
octopi moving shadow it's a black moving
shadow I think ah what happened where to
go uh I can't sprint I'm trying to
sprint but I can't sprint I'm not sure
what that was I mean I've seen anything
at all I don't know it's kind of hard to
tell because it's in the bottom-left
corner so if you're not watching this at
full screen you might miss something
okay so like here
I don't know where this is waiting I'm
really impressed with some of these
projects of whoa hi hey that's me what's
going on oh I got some sort of helmet I
got like a doom helmet going on I'm
really impressed with some of these
games that came out of the 48 hours
eylem gym I mean they got some serious
polish for just a game that was made so
quick what is in there what is that what
is that light yeah I hear you I've got
the volume way turned up when I put it
down with it I've got the volume like
way turned up so every small every tiny
sound is it
what's going on there okay that's all
cows
I'm trying to look at two places at once
it's very confusing
probably worse for you guys because you
got three places look my beautiful face
and then the gameplay and then the
little iPad that they got in there or
non name-brand whatever the hell oh no I
don't even know if there's a firm
objective set into this game and this
may be a very short playthrough but I'm
more interested in like cuz this is just
really neat what they got going on here
and uh I want to applaud the efforts of
smaller developers especially on making
something experimental like this what
what does that say there were some words
on my screen I'll connect it Oh
narrowing raising a fuss over nothing on
okay I don't see it what's down there oh
man I get in there can I jump in what
would happen if I jumped in with the
game end I get stuck down there maybe no
I don't know who I okay I'm devil okay I
can definitely see myself quite clearly
right here I'm gonna wait to see if
there's actually something following me
okay there's my camera oh I heard
something you can't tell me there wasn't
something okay
okay now what is it something's been
following me this entire time and I'm
gonna find out what it is
who it's a I know there's something in
the black cloud I see I see a figure of
a person not gonna let you touch me
screw you
oh that is creepy odd is really cool I'm
gonna run away now okay but that is
really cool I can't move
okay oh yes oh man that's so cool
reminds me of a game that I played a
long time ago that are not a long time
ago but I can't remember what the name
of it was but you got these goggles and
the only way to see the invisible
monster was to pulse the goggles but I
like this implementation more because
it's slightly awkward but that's not a
bad thing because game clayed kind of
kind of kind of matches it because it's
very difficult to keep an eye on
everything unless you know that it's
always there okay there's something in
this room and I'm about to walk into
some computer monitor what is this a
personal log entry open hey family I
can't go into much detail of course but
we've got a well sort of test I'm bit
nervous but we have good people here
they'll look after me oh my love as
always thanks for the model airship I
love it Sophie
okay does that mean whoa what hap oh oh
okay there's some sort of light here hmm
oh is it there is it there
oh it's blocking me oh god it's coming I
see okay ACK oh this might be it
no it's your body the other side of you
I see I see a body where to go where to
go where to go where to go where to go
hey dump dump dump oh I'm stuck yeah I'm
stuck hey come on oh I might be dead
pretty go where to go I hear it I don't
see it though where is it where is it
disappeared
learn it it is a beer do whatever okay
seriously 48 hours 48 hours I don't know
where it is
I think it's right in front of me I
think he's right in front of me read
with me
I think it's right to my left now that
is very disconcerting not to be able to
see where it is all the time
because that's why I like it better than
the goggles because with the goggles you
could just pulse at any time it was
basically like an inconvenience to not
see them but this part of the game to
walk around with it knob there could be
like a seriously well-made game out of
this I mean obviously this is just a
prototype but it's really good really
cool
I just love interesting and intuitive
this might have been done before I don't
know but I've never seen it done like
this in a game okay am I am I my above
ground or am I in space is that sound oh
hello
there's another monitor in here let me
go read it yeah yeah I'm about to get
you hey I hear it again oh those toilets
oh man in space it must suck group
showers and everything notice all
personnel could you please refrain from
dump dropping litter down the toilets
also please stop crapping in the bins
haha cameras have been installed to
catch the culprit who would
nevermind nothing trash in the toilets
crapping in the bands well it's a little
confusing don't you think I don't know
there's a lot of ladies even the model
even the animation of this character is
very well done and it's barely even
noticed because you're just slightly on
camera how this the well maybe oh it's
down this always and it's down there's
only is it is it gonna get me oh maybe
you can't get me I don't know I think I
might've walked right through it okay
let me just explore for a little bit
more because there's a lot to this level
I don't think I've quite gone everywhere
yet it's definitely something have I
been in this from you big and empty I
don't see anything in it I don't think
anything happened when it got to me hang
on I'm gonna wait right here I'm gonna
I'm gonna let it get close I'm gonna let
it actually get me okay there it is oh
no creepy it's coming towards me and it
stopped it stopped right there in front
of me it's not moving but if I go
towards it okay it's right it's like
inches from my face where does that two
inches from my face but I can see
hey I'm standing in it I'm standing
right in it okay right there okay don't
small man's good I was tucked to my own
spit okay so I don't think it's gonna do
anything to me all right so all right
remember this is just a prototype so he
obviously it isn't finished there's a
lot of work left to be done but for 48
hours
this is amazing all right that's all I'm
gonna play for it for now but still guys
you got to admit there's been a lot of
love put in this game and I really do
appreciate the effort that they put
through it is so cool and that is so
creepy I just wish it had some more of a
threat right now but 48 hours where's
okay I'm all done really cool really
cool whoever made this there isn't even
really a lot of information on the maker
uh where I got it I'm gonna hang on the
last thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna see
what's in this pit here seems to be some
like submarine type things up okay
wait oh you can see my beam of light
coming out of the pit okay maybe this is
underwater because he seemed like to be
submersed balls obviously not textured
but that's okay I'll forgive ya I don't
know I guess that's it then
alright that's all for this playthrough
oh I love stuff like this I get tickled
every time I see a really cool feature
like this as opposed to all the the
drudgery and the crap that gets through
the indie game community it's nice to
see some real talent beat and put into
something so if you developer this if
you're watching this you got a lot
potential here I love this
I would love this view this made into a
game I bet you put this forward or put
some like a couple weeks into a playable
demo of a real game you could have uh
you could have a serious Kickstarter on
your hand you could have a serious game
going so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation
it is that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
you should be able to find tons of
seasons
the hell happened
haha
twelve more to go Avengers all over
[Music]
an inkling
ah